In the case of pipe and filter,
we break the system into independently
executing components called filters.
The filters are connected
together using a FIFO, or
first in first out queue, and
these queues are called pipes.
So we have pipes connecting
together the filters.
Each of the filters is going to take
a single input, which has become
called the standard input, and
it's going to produce a single output,
which has now been called
the standard output.
The filters share the assumptions
that the inputs and
output consist of sequential files
containing lines of ASCII characters.
Can you think of a situation
where you have a pipeline of
filter components where it's non-ASCII?
>> I mean,
I guess you could pipe together
Linux processes that have binary output,
but.
>> Yeah, but what-
>> Useful.
>> Well, okay.
>> In terms of, like, a user interface,
you wouldn't be seeing
anything that might be useful.
>> Well, it turns out that in
doing image processing, okay,
you put various filters along the way to
deal with the processing of the images.
Also in situations where there's
sensor data and you want to filter out
noise of certain kinds or select
certain frequency bands and so on.
It's binary data, but
it's going through a filtering process.
So although this does work in other
situations, it's most familiar and
most used in situations
where there's text files.
So as you've indicated, there's going to
be filters having to do with circular
shifting, and alphabetizing, and reading
things in and putting things out.
And one of the essential elements of
this particular approach to solving
things is there's no common
data storage elements.
We're just passing
the solution along as we go.